ahora bien el último enlace del que
vamos a hablar se conoce como enlace
metálico
tomemos uno de nuestros átomos metálicos
por aquí por ejemplo el hierro el hierro
es un buen ejemplo porque es tal vez uno
de los metales a los que más se hace
referencia así que imagina que tenemos
un montón de átomos de hierro efe efe
efe fm espero que puedas leerlos todos
son átomos de hierro y si se encuentran
solos son átomos neutros pero cuando
están muy cerca unos de otros forman un
enlace metálico lo cual tiene sentido
porque son metales y lo que es
interesante de los enlaces metálicos
que a los metales les gusta compartir
sus electrones con otros metales y
forman lo que se conoce como un mar de
electrones entonces se puede ver algo
así cada átomo de hierro pierde un
electrón vamos a dibujarlo por aquí más
grande este es efe positivo es decir
tiene una carga positiva
efe positivo tiene una carga positiva
efe positivo puedes pensar en todos
estos como iones de hierro estamos
imaginando que tienen una carga positiva
porque todos contribuyeron con un
electrón a este mar de electrones
tenemos un electrón aquí con una carga
negativa y obviamente los electrones no
son tan grandes pero la idea es que
podamos verlos así que puedes imaginar
que estos iones positivos se sienten
atraídos por este mar de negatividad
este mar de electrones u otra forma de
pensar en esto es que cuando los metales
forman enlaces metálicos tendrán
electrones de valencia que se superponen
y estos electrones de valencia no están
fijos a un solo átomo sino que pueden
moverse alrededor esto es lo que hace
que los metales tengan varias de las
características que asociamos con ellos
por ejemplo pueden conducir la
electricidad ya que estos electrones
pueden moverse por allí con bastante
facilidad y bueno otra característica es
la maleabilidad lo que quiere decir que
se pueden doblar fácilmente puedes
imaginar los iones de hierro en este
pudín o en este mar de electrones y así
que puedes doblarlos y no se romperán en
cambio si tomamos una barra de sal por
acá e intentamos doblarla es bastante
rígida y se romperá aquí están estos son
los distintos tipos de enlaces es
importante enfatizar que podemos ver
esto como un espectro en un extremo
tenemos cosas como en los enlaces
iónicos donde un átomo toma una
de otro átomo y dice hey
ahora hay una atracción entre nosotros
por ejemplo la sal y tenemos enlaces
covalentes donde los electrones se
comparten en igual medida y hay otros
enlaces entre los enlaces covalentes y
los enlaces iónicos donde los electrones
no se comparten de igual manera entre
los átomos
estos son los enlaces covalentes polares
y por último una forma extrema de
compartir los electrones ocurre con los
enlaces metálicos donde tenemos este mar
de electrones